[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wir auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport von mir schauen wir auf
die Nachrichten Themen von heute
Streik abgewendet Deutsche Post und die
Gewerkschaft Verdi einigen sich auf
einen neuen Tarifvertrag
Diskussion über Waffenrecht nach dem
Amoklauf in Hamburg will Innenministerin
Fräser eine weitere Gesetzesverschärfung
prüfen
und die beste der Geschichte Micaela
shiffrin feiert ihren 87 Weltcup Sieg
und steigt auf zur alleinigen
Rekordhalterin
[Musik]
wir sehensüchtig auf einen Brief oder
ein Paket wartet kann aufatmen es wird
wohl keinen Streik bei der Post geben
der Konzern und die Gewerkschaft Verdi
haben sich dann doch noch
zusammengerauft für die
160.000 Beschäftigten gibt es laut Post
Gehaltsverbesserungen von
durchschnittlich 11,5 Prozent plus
Sonderzahlung Ariane Güdel hat Details
ein Streik ist ziemlich sicher vom Tisch
Post und Verdi sprechen von extrem
schwierigen Verhandlungen aber der
Durchbruch scheint gelungen nach vier
Verhandlungsrunden eine Einigung für die
rund 160.000 Tarifbeschäftigten der Post
beide Seiten zeigen sich zu frieden wir
haben jetzt ein gutes Ergebnis erzielt
mit deutlichen Verbesserungen im
Verhältnis zum ersten Angebot und das
haben wir den Druck den unsere
Mitglieder auch auf die Arbeitgeber
entfaltet haben zu verdanken
und so sieht die Einigung aus ab 1 April
nächsten Jahres für alle 340 € monatlich
mehr laut Post eine durchschnittliche
Lohnerhöhung um 11,5% hinzu kommt eine
Sonderzahlung von 3000 € in Tranchen ab
April 23 Laufzeit 24 Monate
trotz schwächelnden Brief und
Paketgeschäft zeigt sich auch die Post
zufrieden wir sind im Interesse unserer
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter aber
auch unsere Kunden über unsere
finanzielle Schmerzgrenze hinausgegangen
wichtig ist dass wir längere Streiks
zulassen unserer Kunden und des
Unternehmens vermeiden konnten
Verdi Mitglieder müssen jetzt noch
einmal in einer Uhr Abstimmung den
bereits beschlossenen Streit ad acta
legen
neu Warnstreiks gibt es dagegen wieder
an Flughäfen am Montag müssen sich
Reisende auf erhebliche Verspätungen und
Flugausfälle einstellen wäre die hat es
Sicherheitspersonal aufgerufen die
Arbeit niederzulegen an den Flughäfen in
Berlin Hamburg Hannover und Bremen
hätten schärfere Waffengesetze den
Amoklauf in Hamburg mit 8 Toten
verhindert ist der Täter zu einfach an
seine Waffe gekommen darüber wird jetzt
intensiv diskutiert über 100 Mal hatte
ein Sportschütze vorgestern mit seiner
halbautomatischen Pistole auf die
Besucher eines Gottesdienstes der Zeugen
Jehovas geschossen Christian Volk
berichtet
blumenkerzen Andenken in Hamburg
versuchen die Menschen das Unfassbare zu
verarbeiten in die Trauer mischt sich
Wut viele fordern ein strengeres
Waffenrecht einen bereits vorgelegten
Gesetzentwurf will Innenministerin Feser
überprüfen bisher unter anderem geplant
ein Verbot kriegswaffenähnlicher
halbautomatischer Langwaffen die
Hamburger Tatwaffe eine halbautomatische
Pistole würde nicht darunter fallen sie
müssen immer die Balance auch halten für
diejenigen die natürlich ihr gutes Recht
haben auch Sportschützen sind und man
will die natürlich nicht behelligen aber
ich glaube auch im Namen der
Sportschützen und Jäger ist es ja im
großen Interesse dass wir Extremisten
aussortieren und dass sie eben keine
Waffen bekommen Philipp F war
Sportschütze besaß die Waffe legal war
aber womöglich psychisch krank er habe
besondere Wut auf religiöse Anhänger so
ein anonymer Hinweis in Zukunft soll
jeder neue Waffenbesitzer auf seine
psychologische Eignung geprüft werden
dafür brauche es aber keine
Gesetzesänderung sagt der Koalition
Partner FDP das deutsche Waffenrecht ist
bereits sehr streng und das ist auch gut
so den Menschen die eine psychische
Erkrankung haben die dürfen keine
Schusswaffe besitzen das hat diese
schreckliche Tat in Hamburg gezeigt und
jetzt muss herausgearbeitet werden warum
die Waffenbehörde die waffenrechtliche
Erlaubnis eigentlich nicht entzogen hat
obwohl sie von der psychischen
Erkrankung wusste auch waffenexperten
sehen die Probleme nicht den
Gesetzestexten sondern in deren
Anwendung wir haben bis zu 600
verschiedene Behörden in der
Bundesrepublik die sich Sachenrecht
zuständig um diesen voll zu kümmern das
ist vollkommen unbefriedigend und
schafft riesengroße Lücken die dann
solche Taten wie den armutlauf von
Hamburg überhaupt erst möglich
was die Tat in Hamburg für das
Waffenrecht bedeutet das soll kommende
Woche Thema im Innenausschuss sein
wir haben den Stresstest bestanden so
wertete heute zumindest der Vorsitzende
der Deutschen Bischofskonferenz
Betzingen den Abschluss des sogenannten
Synodalen Wegs dieser Reform Dialog war
vor drei Jahren als Reaktion auf den
Missbrauchskandal in der katholischen
Kirche gestartet worden seither Ringen
katholische Bischöfe und Laienvertreter
um Themen wie Sexualmoral den Zölibat
macht und Gewaltenteilung in der Kirche
so wie die Rolle von Frauen jetzt gibt
es tatsächlich Ergebnisse bei einigen
droht der Konflikt mit Drogen Klinge
der Jubel ist groß als die
synodalversammlung den Text zur
Anerkennung der geschlechtlichen
Vielfalt annimmt das Thema war
umstritten Mara klein definiert sich als
non binär und ist froh gerade sind meine
Augen trocken aber ja also es war so
viel Anspannung die letzten drei Tage
für mich bis heute morgen habe ich
gedacht dass der Text durchfällt
ich weiß gar nicht genau was ich gerade
fühle große anleistung
Erleichterung außerdem als klar wird
dass Frauen künftig Diakoninnen sein
dürfen in der katholischen Kirche
stehender Applaus auch von Bischöfen
Priesterin sollen Frauen aber noch nicht
werden das Priesteramt bleibt angestrebt
wir haben auch im Grundtext deutlich
gesagt Öffnung für alle Dienste und
Ämter drei Jahre lang wurde auf dem
Synodalen Weg dem Reformprozess der
katholischen Kirche um Veränderungen
gerungen es gab Kompromisse und manch
konservativer unter den Bischöfen hat
sich bewegt zumindest von einer
ablehnenden Position in Richtung
Enthaltung das Resüme ist durchaus
positiv nämlich wir sind zusammen
geblieben es war ja oft von
Zerreißproben die Rede
vor der Tür auch Proteste Gläubiger
denen hier schon zu viel entschieden
wurde so soll der Papst gebeten werden
die Aufhebung des Pflicht Zölibats zu
prüfen Segens Feiern für homosexuelle
Paare sind künftig erlaubt das ist ein
anderes Verhalten ein anderes Handeln
der Kirche und darauf warten ganz ganz
viele Menschen in unseren Gemeinden und
ich hoffe dass es sie auch beflügelt
wieder auf andere zuzugehen die den
Kontakt zur Kirche vielleicht längst
aufgegeben haben
die Themen des Synodalen Wegs werden in
einer kleineren Gruppe weiter besprochen
offen ist zum Beispiel noch die Frage ob
Bischöfe und Laien in Zukunft gemeinsam
Entscheidungen treffen dürfen
das wollen wir einordnen mit Jürgen
Erbacher unserem Experten für die
katholische Kirche Jürgen trotz dieser
Ergebnisse sind viele Laien enttäuscht
von dem Abschluss wurde da eine Chance
verpasst ja beherztreformen angehen das
geht sicherlich an dass viele Gläubigen
haben sich entschiedenere Entscheidungen
gewünscht zum Beispiel bei der
Gleichberechtigung bei Entscheidungen
von Laien und Bischöfen oder das
Priesteramt für die Frau dennoch die
Beschlüsse zeigen dass nicht nur die
Mehrheit der Gläubigen Veränderungen
will sondern auch die Mehrheit der
Bischöfe nicht mit der Brechstange aber
Schritt für Schritt damit soll auch den
konservativen eine Brücke sozusagen
geboten werden dass sie damit können die
Laien die werden jetzt genau schauen
dass das was in den Texten steht auch
wirklich umgesetzt wird und sie haben
auch schon deutlich gemacht sie wollen
natürlich mehr und weitere Veränderungen
auch fordern ganz entscheidend dabei ist
aber wieder Papst und der Vatikan darauf
reagieren und die sehen diesen deutschen
Weg ja durchaus kritisch ja da gab es in
den letzten Monaten immer wieder
heftigen Gegenwind sind zu klarer Absage
an Zentrale reformanliegen des Synodalen
Wegs der wird sich vermutlich jetzt
erstmal nichts ändern und auch die
Gegner von Reformen werden versuchen aus
hohem Rückendeckung zu bekommen da hilft
nichts außer vielleicht
kirchenpolitische Pendel Diplomatie jede
Menge Gespräche der reformbischöfe mit
dem Papst und auch vatikanischen stellen
außerdem hat franziskus ja einen
weltweiten Synodalen Prozess also
Beratungsprozess angestoßen da sieht man
diese reformthemen werden in vielen
Ländern diskutiert wenn die Bischöfe
jetzt Verbündete finden in anderen
Ländern für ihre Anliegen dann wird es
für Rom schwieriger einzelne Prozesse in
einzelnen Ländern auszubremsen dennoch
das Brett ist dick dass da jetzt in Rom
zu bohren ist wichtige Einschätzung
vielen Dank Jürgen Erbacher
seit Monaten kritisiert die Europäische
Union die milliardenschweren
us-subventionen für umweltfreundliche
Technologien Europa fürchtet
Wettbewerbsnachteile für die eigene
heimische Industrie eine Annäherung gab
es nun bei den Gesprächen von
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
gestern mit US-Präsident beiden demnach
ist ein Abkommen über Mineralien für
Autobatterien geplant in Europa
hergestellte Elektrofahrzeuge kämen dann
auch beim Verkauf in den USA für
Steuererleichterungen in Frage
in Den Haag sind heute Tausende zum
Protest auf die Straße gegangen Grund
sind die angestrebten klimaauflagen für
die niederländische Landwirtschaft die
Bauern fühlen sich durch die
angekündigten Auflagen in ihrer Existenz
bedroht bis 2030 will die Koalition von
premier rütte den Stickstoffeintrag
drastisch reduzieren den Klimaschützern
gehen die Vorhaben der Regierung nicht
weit genug sie blockierten die Autobahn
weil sie im Verkehr den größten
Umweltverschmutzer sehen
die Morde des rechtsextremen NSU der
Anschlag auf dem Berliner
Breitscheidplatz oder Hanau auch in
Deutschland hat Terror viele Leben
gekostet viel Leid verursacht zum
zweiten Mal gibt es heute den nationalen
Gedenktag für die Opfer terroristischer
Gewalt doch von manchen wird er
boykottiert wie lass uns berichtet
um genau sie geht es an diesem Gedenktag
Opfer Hinterbliebene und andere
Betroffene von Terror und Gewalt doch
nicht alle sind der Einladung der
Bundesregierung gefolgt ich weiß manche
von ihnen die hier sind und auch einige
die nicht hier sind empfinden
Verbitterung
manche finden dieser Tag komme zu spät
Interviews des Justizministeriums zeigen
woran es in der Vergangenheit häufig
gemangelt hat an Empathie und
entschlossener Hilfe viele Opfer fühlen
sich allein gelassen die Überbringung
der Todesnachricht hat stattgefunden in
dem in Polizist die Namen verlesen hat
und man dann einfach nach Hause
geschickt wurde und jetzt kämpfe ich
seit fünf Jahren um eine
opferentschädigungsrente
und es ist genau das gleiche Desaster
wie vor
wie vor 40 Jahren auch als ich meine
Therapiekosten haben wollte es ist mein
Schicksal mein Vater wurde ermordet aber
es hätte auch jeden treffen können alle
Redner beschwören die Abwehrbereitschaft
des Staates gegen Terror und Gewalt der
Hass der Täter wird uns nicht zum Hass
verführen
und unser Zusammenhalt wird nicht
schwächer er wird stärker wenn wir
bedroht und angegriffen werden eine
eindrückliche Gedenkveranstaltung
verbunden mit dem Versprechen der
Bundesregierung mit dem Betroffenen
künftig einfühlsamer und angemessener
umzugehen
aufatmen nach der Geiselnahme in einer
Apotheke in Karlsruhe die Polizei konnte
alle Geiseln befreien alle blieben
unverletzt der mutmaßliche Täter hatte
sie mit einer Schreckschusspistole
bedroht der 20-Jährige ist Polizei
bekannt elf Menschen waren gestern fast
fünf Stunden in seiner Gewalt am
Abendstunden dann Spezialkräfte die
Apotheke und nahmen ihn fest
es hat ein bisschen was von schöner
neuer Welt die Bildungsmesse die didacta
demonstrierte in Stuttgart wie
spielerisch Kinder zukünftig lernen
könnten wenn ja wenn die Schulen in
Deutschland entsprechend digital
ausgestattet wären Sven Klasse hat mehr
auch so könnte in Zukunft
Matheunterricht aussehen und so könnten
Schüler per virtual reality-brille in
die Mondlandung eintauchen die
Digitalisierung war ein Schwerpunkt der
Bildungsmesse didacta die
Einsatzmöglichkeiten in der Praxis
scheinen riesig man jetzt
dass man da irgendwie mit spielen oder
so halt in dem Game schaut wie man zum
Beispiel Handstand lernt oder bestimmte
Sachen lernt vielleicht auch in
Geschichte um dann eben sich da in die
Situation gut einzuführen an dieser
Gemeinschaftsschule in Vaihingen an der
Enz in Baden-Württemberg nutzen Sie
schon Lasercutter im Unterricht die
Schüler können programmieren welche
Teile der Laserstrahl aus dem Holz
schneiden soll sie haben Drohnen deren
Flugbewegung die Schüler digital
festlegen und speichern und Touchscreen
Tische mit denen beispielsweise Filme
animiert werden können doch nur an
wenigen Schulen ist die Digitalisierung
so weit fortgeschritten bewegt sich was
in die richtige Richtung
weil auch wenn wir halt quasi uns
vergleichen mit anderen Ländern auch
dort ist es so dass die die vor fünf
Jahren schon vorne dabei waren die
entwickeln sich ja auch weiter
Deutschland international nur Mittelmaß
und selbst dann vorzeigeschulen wie ein
Vaihingen haben sie Alltagsprobleme zu
langsames WLAN fehlendes Personal zu
Wartung digitaler Geräte immerhin die
sind dann vielen Schulen inzwischen
angekommen oft finanziert mit Mitteln
aus dem ersten digitalpakt von Bund und
Ländern und nun digitalpakt 2 dringend
notwendig da haben wir uns auch im
Koalitionsvertrag ja auf Bundesebene
darauf verständigt und daher sind wir da
momentan den Verhandlungen die
Möglichkeiten durch die Digitalisierung
für Schulen sind riesig die
Herausforderungen aber auch
und jetzt zur besten Skirennläuferin der
Weltnummer Mikaela chiffrin klettert
jeden Tag ein bisschen höher im Olymp
das läuft wie am Fließband bei der
US-Amerikanerin gestern hatte sie in
eure mit dem Weltcup-Sieg Nummer 86 die
Rekordmarke des legendären Schweden
ingemars denn Marc von 1989 erreicht
heute mit Sieg Nummer 87 nun die neue
besten Marke
die erfolgreichste Ski Allrounderin der
Welt ist nun auch die beste alpinen
skisportgeschichte die US-Amerikanerin
Michaela shiffrin einen Weltcup Triumph
mehr als der Schwede Inge Masten mag der
das aber ausschließlich im Slalom und
Riesenslalom geschafft hat shiffrin aber
in allen Disziplinen sie die mit 17
bereits Weltmeisterin wurde und nach
Rückschlägen immer wieder zurückgekommen
ist ihre wahre Größe hängt da nicht nur
an fünf Gesamtweltcup siegen oder der
Zahl 87 sogar 100 Weltcup Erfolge sind
ihr jetzt zuzutrauen
zwei dritte Plätze für die deutschen
biathlonstaffeln beim Weltcup in
Östersund bei den Frauen übergab Vanessa
Vogt anschlussläuferin Denise Hermann
Wick da lag Deutschland noch gleich auf
mit Frankreich dann aber brauchte die
34-Jährige beim Schießen insgesamt fünf
Nachlader der Staffel sieging an
Norwegen vor Frankreich und bei den
Männern dagegen sorgte der Schlussläufer
für den Podestplatz Benedikt doll nutzen
die Patzer der Konkurrenz und der
kämpfte für das DSV Quartet Rang 3
ebenfalls hinter Norwegen und Frankreich
Skispringer Karl Geiger ist in Oslo bei
der RAW Air Tour dank eines furiosen
zweiten Sprungs auf Podest geflogen er
wurde dritter nach dem ersten Durchgang
lag er nur auf Platz 13 zur
Fußball-Bundesliga die Bayern haben
durch den Sieg gegen Augsburg die
Tabellenführung verteidigt hier die
bisherigen Ergebnisse des Spieltags der
FCB bezwingt den FCA mit 5 zu 3 Hertha
und Mainz trennen sich eins zu eins
Leipzig schlägt Gladbach 13:0 Frankfurt
gegen Stuttgart 1:1 das Abendspiel
Schalke gegen Dortmund und bereits
gestern unter der Köln Bochum mit 0:2
kurzer Blick auf die Tabelle die Bayern
bleiben auf jeden Fall an der Spitze vor
Dortmund Leipzig rauf auf Rang 3 vor
Union Freiburg und Frankfurt ja und am
Tabellen Ende klettert Bochum nach den
Sieg gegen Köln von 18 auf 14 vor Hertha
Stuttgart Hoffenheim und Schlusslicht
Schalke
und das hundertste Revier Derby zwischen
Schalke und Dortmund später bei uns
ausführlich im Aktuellen Sportstudio zu
sehen um 23:30 Uhr zu Gast könntest
Trainer Stefan Baumgart
Englands fußballikone Gary Lineker sorgt
für Aufsehen nachdem er in einem Tweet
die Einwanderungspolitik der britischen
Regierung scharf kritisiert hatte wurde
er von der BBC für heute als Moderator
der fußballsendung match of the day
suspendiert es folgten zahlreiche
Solidaritätsbekundungen mit dem
62-Jährigen und viele britische
Fußballer wollen der BBC deshalb keine
Interviews mehr geben mehr Infos bei uns
auf ZDF heute und in der ZDF heute App
ja und auch noch was fußballerisches aus
England überraschende Niederlage für
Jürgen Klopp und seine Reds
Liverpool in den weißen Trikots verliert
nur zu eins beim Tabellen letzten bornes
Philipp Benning trifft in der 28 Minute
nach der 7 zu 0 heimgaler gegen
Manchester United am letzten Samstag
eine kalte Dusche Liverpool bleibt
zunächst aber der Bellen Fünfter
das war's vom Sport euer reichlich
absolut nicht gerne der Sonntag wird
nass und bringt etwas Regen Schnee
Details hat gleich Christa auch bin
viertel nach elf grüß Sie Christian
Sievers im heute journal wir sagen danke
und tschüss und bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen machen sie sich ein schönes
Wochenende
[Musik]
guten Abend endlich mal wieder eine
ordentliche wechselhafte
westwindwetterlage die Tiefs geben sich
die Klinke in die Hand morgen überquert
uns eine Warmfront mit etwas Schnee und
Regen das ist wirklich gut für die Natur
im Moment schon am Montag gibt es neuen
Regen Sturm und einen ordentlichen
warmluftschub so geht es auch mit den
Temperaturen im Moment auf und ab bis
Montag erreichen im ganzen Land
zweistellige Werte schon Mitte nächster
Woche liegen wir aber wieder im
einstelligen Bereich und die Nächte
liegen um 0 Grad heute Nacht ist es
sowieso verbreitet frostig nur im Westen
plus ein Garten im Osten bis -5 Grad
verbreitet wird es wieder glatt im Osten
klar ist heute Nacht oft auf im Westen
reichen uns schon die Wolken die erst
Schnee dann Regen bringen so gibt's dann
morgen Vormittag zwischen der Nordsee
und Südbayern auch etwas Schnee dahinter
folgt etwas Regen zwischen der Ostsee
und dem Erzgebirge startet der Tag recht
freundlich nachmittags verlagern sich
Schnee und Regen aber hierhin und im
Westen lockert es auf dieses Band sieht
insgesamt aber recht schnell also kommen
nicht mehr als zwei drei Liter pro
Quadratmeter oder mal eine dünne
Schneedecke zusammen dazu ein lebhaften
Südwestwind die Temperaturen ähnlich wie
heute drei bis sechs Grad nur im
Südwesten spülen wir schon diese milden
10 bis 15 Grad weil der Südwestwind am
Montag stürmisch wird gibt es einen
kurzen 21 Grad Frühlingstag im Südwesten
schon am Dienstag ist es wieder kühler
am Mittwoch gibt es auch vermehrt wieder
Schnee also es bleibt abwechslungsreich
tschüss